Hello and welcome to fire learning.
Often when we talk about the
evolution of our animal companions,
we focused on the gradual
transition from wolves to dogs,
but how about our feline friends?
Well,
in this video we're going
to explore how cats evolved.
The line that led the cats broke off
from the line that led to other failings
such as lions and tigers, only about
10 million years ago, much later,
cats probably quite simply evolved from
the African wild cats Faley Sylvestri
sleeve.
It costs about 10,000 years ago,
which looks much more like a
modern cat than a wolf does.
The average modern dog and
in fact actually exhibits
much more similar behavior
to modern domestic cats
and dogs and wolves.
Do and we'll get to that in a second
though we can still obviously easily
contrasted to though humans did in fact
a medicaid other cat like animals and
other parts of the world.
Genetic studies have shown that all
domestic cats around today are descended
from the aforementioned African wild
cat with whom they share the closest DNA
match. Now, the date of 8,000 BC,
10,000 years ago is important and it
can be contrasted with dogs who were
domesticated a few thousand years earlier.
Dogs were used by our ancestors primarily
for hunting and protection and things
like that,
but the evolution of the cad coincides
directly in the same time as and in the
same place as the origin of farming
10,000 years ago in the Middle East.
That's a real likely,
not a coincidence.
Cats were very likely not
used for plowing fields,
but they almost certainly were involved
in the food production process or more
specifically food preservation process.
How well rodents,
the food produced by humans at this time
was of course at risk from infestation
by rodents and rather than have the humans
take care of the problem themselves,
they probably simply adopted
the cat to do its job.
Gradually friendlier and friendlier.
Cats were more open to
interaction with humans.
The humans dust domesticated them and
we entered into a fair mutual exchange
card, our food, which attracts mice
and you can keep all the mice you find.
However,
the steel wasn't probably so solidified
in pursuit of a process as it was with
dogs cause aren't quite as social as
dark because I don't interact with us in
the same way and they don't follow our
commands as well as any cat owner would
tell you. What happened with cats
was probably more so a coincidence,
more like biological mutualism, then
specific directed artificial selection.
Some would even say that if humans were
looking to control the rodent population
there would have been better animals at
a time to domesticate and utilize it in
the cat.
The very first evidence we have of cat
domestication comes from the island of
Cyprus around 9,500 years ago.
The year 7,500 BC alongside human remains.
Presumably the former owners,
this location and men are variable are
both important and providing evidence
that this was indeed the time in
which cats were domesticated as a,
there were no cast native to the island
to begin with and seeing as how cats are
stereotypically not fond of swimming,
someone would've had to have
brought them there and be one,
would very likely not bury
themselves with a wild animal,
especially one is trivial as a wild cat.
So assuredly by this time humans and cats,
we're living together.
Cats played the in modern human
civilization as well. In ancient Egypt,
the charge for killing a cat, it was
often the same as killing another person,
which was often death.
This was due to the CAS importance
in Egypt and religious practice.
The Romans helps spread cats across
Europe where they were valued as an
independent pet and seen as a symbol of
individual liberty actually and during
this time cast spread at the Far
East as well. In the Middle Ages,
cats were seen as a symbol
of bad luck and they,
especially black hats were warded off
and sometimes killed go naturally.
They going to come back and today there
are an estimated 600 million domestic
has around the world.
So that's how the domestic cat
evolved into its current form.
If you're interested in hearing how any
other animals evolved and Mesic or not,
let me know in the comments section
below and I may do a video on it.
And more videos like these and
videos on many other subjects.
We should have checked out
five of learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.